hi I'm tro FL wait no I'm I'm Sam Ryan
you might remember me from hit shows
such as studying the galactic sausage
and sausage ly A Tail of Two sausages
and also this derin shirt it's beautiful
it's fashion I know what you're thinking
you're not Simon and that's correct no I
do not have a PhD and I also do not have
a plastic crack addiction though those
two things are very close to becoming
true no Simon is on paternity leave and
so has asked me to create a video Worthy
of Mordor and that is what I'm going to
do today I'm going to talk to you about
some exciting recent developments in the
field of exod planets I'm a current
fourth year at The Institute of
astronomy in the University of Cambridge
at St Catherine's College studying
Galactic archaeology and you might be
asking what does the history of the
Milky Way and its Dynamics have to do
with exoplanets it has nothing really
and I don't study exoplanets I actually
don't know anything about exoplanets so
I've got three amazing academics who
will do that job for me starting in the
past with Lord Martin Ree the astronomer
Royal one of my third-year mates talking
about the recent discovery of k218b
finishing with Professor Jerry Gilmore
on how guia the best satellite ever will
be revolutionizing the detection of
exoplanets so I first asked Martin Reese
how did we get to where exoplanet
science is today I'm Martin Reese and
we're talking in the astronomy Institute
of Cambridge I've been a member for a
long time and was director of The
Institute into lard I do remember that
and um it was a exciting result of
course and in the next 10 years we had
lots more exoplanets and so it became
clear that most stars in the sky had
retinues of orbiting planets just like
the sun has the earth and the other
familiar planets and this makes the
night sky far more interesting and then
of course this raised higher on the
agenda the question of could there be
any life out there in the case of all
new discoveries you start off with just
a few puzzling objects and maybe rather
crude observations people focus on those
particular objects and things eventually
firm up the understanding is very crude
and that develops a bit and I think over
the years I had written some of the
early papers on trying to make sense of
some of those strange animals in the
cosmic Zoo as it were found by x-ray
astronomers and By Radio astronomers and
by the uh big optical telescopes the
kind of work I did was based on um very
simple model way you you think the
sperical or smooth Etc what's been a
huge boost to astronomy has been the um
ability to do computer simulations and
it's for that reason that we can now
study how gas with magnetic fields
orbits around black holes and swirls
into them and understand the uh way in
which our universe evolved from its
fairly smooth Beginnings to the present
um Universe dominated by galaxies and
clusters it's it's a great Triumph but
still the data is limited and uh to
actually get an image of a earth like P
is is going to be difficult but that's
the
challenge so I'm standing here in
Neville's Court in triny college in
Cambridge where a couple hundred years
ago a certain Isaac Newton discovered
the Speed of Sound by just clapping his
hands even though it has nothing to do
with exoplanets I just thought it was
neat that was the past though and well
we're now in the present so I was joined
by fellow third-year Ms who worked on
the recent discovery of
k218b my name is mberg I'm a thirdy year
PhD student here at the Institute of
astronomy I do exoplanet atmospheres
specifically data analysis we only look
at transiting planets so if you have
your star and your planet goes in front
of it and some of the Starlight is
passing through the atmosphere so then
we take observations throughout the
whole thing when it paes in front of the
star and then essentially we have only
the Starlight when the planet is not
transiting and when the planet is
transiting we can take the difference of
those two and that Spectrum has
imprinted spectral features which tell
us what Atomic and molecular species are
in the atmosphere so with the new James
Webb Space Telescope we've been able to
probe atmospheres of exoplanets to much
higher Precision so now when we can
shrink down those errors we can really
start to see the features of the
Spectrum in much more clarity we found
the first first evidence of
photochemistry on a hot Jupiter that was
sulfur dioxide uh was found in the
atmosphere and the only way you can
produce that is through photochemistry I
think it was predicted to be there but
no one really expected it they found a
bump which they couldn't explain
initially then they had to add the
molecule and then ah it matches so that
was an new unexpected Discovery more
recently the k218b Spectra where we
found methane and carbon dioxide for the
first time in a planet in the habitable
zone it was an international team led by
Nik Madam here in Cambridge I've done
the the data analysis or or as as part
of a team we've done the data analysis
taking the the raw data that comes from
the telescope uh when it beams down the
the ones and zeros and then processing
the data trying to figure out like how
much flux uh actually hit the detector
and then how that produce a spectrum
that you can then compare to to these
models where we took two observations uh
with two different instruments of k218b
and this has been proposed to be a
possible hyen world and here hen means a
mini Neptune with a possible liquid
water ocean and a hydrogen layer on top
an atmosphere we saw big spectral
features uh right away they could be
seen by eye you didn't have to run a
retrieval uh essentially I mean we did
but just the fact that you can see the
features so clearly which wasn't
possible before people thought that was
water uh but in reality with our our
more accurate observations over a
broader wavelength range show that those
features were actually due to methane so
when we look at the distribution of
planets that we have found so far the
most common type of Planet lies
somewhere between Earth in size and
Neptune and we don't really have an
analog of that in in the solar system so
hyen was a candidate planet type that
was proposed to maybe be some of these
planets in in between here so we we
found methane and carbon dioxide that
then there was another tentative sign of
uh dimethy sulfide which on Earth is
only produced by life however we need
more observations to to Really confirm
uh these findings there's upcoming
observations of um yeah of I think four
or more um hen candidate worlds so
jwst uh through these observations have
shown that it is capable um to do these
sort of discoveries so I think we're
just in the beginning of of what is to
come I'm here on the backs in Cambridge
known to many hit films such as the
theory of everything and also Simon and
Sam on a cam on the cam and I still not
tried pting since that fateful day but
we've just heard from mons about carbon
dioxide methane and potential bio
signatures I'm next joined by Professor
Jerry Gilmore one of the main piis for
the guy Mission a satellite built by the
European Space Agency with a goal to
understand history and structure the
Milky Way and so far it's revolutionized
Galactic archaeology with the first
three data releases but with the fourth
and fifth coming out between 2025 and
2030 where the field of exoplanets
experience a Kind of cernic Revolution
and so I ask Jerry exactly how will guy
do this I'm Jerry Gilmore I'm professor
of experimental philosophy here at the
Institute of astronomy in Cambridge my
field of research is the local universe
everything from nearby stars and their
chemical elements right through to where
the Milky Way came from the main thing
in which I've been involved for the last
few decades is the guia spacecraft the
ISA Mission I was one of the original
Mini five people who proposed it and I
was on the original team that worked
with industry to design it into its
current magnificent State it's the first
ever large scale space astrometry
mission so that means it it measures
very accurately the position of stars at
a given time by then repeating those
measurements as guire and the Earth
together go around the Sun you see the
stars from different angles and that
gives you a parallax measure in the same
way that our eyes give you a distance
measure you then keep repeating that
over time and you see not only The
Parallax I how far away the star is
which is the reflex Earth motion but you
also see the proper motion of the star
so you get a five-dimensional image of
how the star is moving through the Milky
Way and then you can complement that
with a radial velocity of spectrum guia
does all the bright stars itself which
gives you the sixth Dimension the line
of sight so then you get instantaneously
the three-dimensional position of a star
and its motion in each of those three
dimensions and so you can see how it is
moving around and see how the Milky Way
Works guy was launched just before
Christmas 2013 so it's nearly 10 years
now was originally designed to measure a
billion stars it was called the billion
star surveyor in fact it's done a little
more than 1.8 billion it's produced
about 8,000 papers feature of gy is that
the data is so huge and so complicated
that only about the first third of it
been published so far and so it's only
the first 3 and a half years now if you
want to go looking for exit planets you
have to look for a few years to see the
effect AP part from hot Jupiters or
something where things are happening on
a time scale every day guia is still
operating it's got to B another 18
months before it runs out of fuel and
over its lifetime it will have been
operating for about 11 years and so over
that 11 year time it's going to be
fantastic for exoplanets even the next
data release which is still only going
to be the first half of the data first 5
years or 5 and a half years will be
fantastic but it it's probable that
perhaps 20,000 planetary systems will be
mapped out by guia but for real detailed
microscopic stuff the number will
probably be less than a thousand we can
say here is a a Neptune of this
particular mass in this particular
period and here is a Uranus and so on
but the the key thing is the guy will
find these systems and then by then we
will have things like the extremely
large telescope with its ultra high
Precision planetary camera and go take
pictures of the stuff yeah and so you go
look so does this planet go white in
Winter and green in summer that sort of
thing the next really big data set which
is the fulltime series never not been
released yet so everybody can go out
then and look and fit their own models
to every object and say what sort of
planets are hiding here or whatever that
will come out at probably the end of 25
so that will be dr4 but that will still
only be the first half of the data so
the second full data release the full
and final one at every single data point
which will be hundreds of trillions of
data points that will probably be about
2030 it'll take another 5 years after
the end of the mission just to do all
the computer processing cuz the numbers
are the data volumes are just huge and
so just takes time to grind them all
through and do everything unlike most
experiments where the people who are the
the science team the project team do the
basic analysis of their data and they
publish the basic important results gu a
few sample results are put out which are
really just educational they're designed
to show the community how to analyze the
data the real exciting thing about guire
is that is a genuine open science
machine it's the first ever open science
machine in which all the data are just
given freely to the whole world and the
whole world gets to do the the exciting
first science It's A Brave New World
something remarkable exhilarating that
we're standing on a precipice of
something generally amazing there's not
much after the future you can't go past
the future so there's not much left in
this video I'm going to hand it over to
myself who will be somewhere else in
Cambridge I'm standing outside the C's
observatories which is not just one
building there are many observatories
all around us but this is the
observatory this is OBS and this was
where emir's people such as Einstein and
Edington sat in that very spot the bench
has now disappeared but there used to be
a bench there talked about edington's
discovery of light bending around the
Sun and in that discussion they changed
our understanding of Relativity and of
the universe obviously this is what this
video has done to you has changed your
perception of exoplanets I think there's
only one thing left which is some words
of encouragement and wisdom from Martin
himself well
I would um extol it as a stimulating
subject uh which does provide um a good
research career for many people in order
to pursue that career then of course you
need a fairly broad scientific
background you need to understand some
mathematics and physics certainly a lot
of computing but now perhaps in biology
as well or complex chemistry so a wide
variety of inputs that we're going to
need to have if you want to try and
interpret what's being found plus of
course uh uh all the variety of
Technologies and um there's lots of
excitement and lots of variety it's
going to be a subject where the ratio of
problems to people is going to remain
gratifyingly high so you can find your
own problem and there won't be too much
duplication Etc and so that's very good
and I think the other feature which is
attractive about the subject is that it
is um something which attracts a far
wider interest among amateurs and the
general public and I think that's a
boost I think it's nice to know that
there's a public interest if I'm sitting
next to someone on a train or on a plane
then if I want to have a conversation I
should say I'm an astronomer and that
will almost certainly the first question
will be are we alone and then you can go
from there whereas if I want to be alone
I just say I'm a mathematician have to
shut them up those were some truly wise
words from Maron there anyway I hope you
all enjoyed this video this exploration
into do past present and future XA
Planet research it's only left for me to
say thank you very much Simon for giving
me this opportunity to speak to the
wider World many people would not give
me this opportunity if they have seen
all the memes all the terrible I'm not
going to say that but if you're starting
your undergrad about now by the time you
do your PhD God help you you'll be
getting there with guy dr4 and
discovering all the new exoplanets you
can find me at over on Twitch every so
often where I do some study streams some
game streams a podcasty talk show stream
and you can find me over there at Sam
wise 2450 and also remember to like
comment and subscribe it's a goodbye
from me goodbye